[Music]  I believe there are answers in the sky  up there is where I have found the  greatest happiness  gentlemen to predict the weather could  save hundreds of thousands of lives  we're scientists not fortune tellers  you'll get your chance they'll realize  you're worth I think they know my worth  quite enough prove them wrong guys I'm a  really good aranaut I want to use what  I'm good at  women don't belong in front those and  she makes such a show of herself miss  Wren I need to make studies of ya I'm  not a coachman for hire you are the only  person who could fly us higher than  anyone has ever been so will you  side begins  [Music]  don't you wish to be up there with him  some reach for the stars some push  others towards me  [Music]  [Applause]  whoo that's get wet is this balloons not  the strongest words ever been even sir I  can't fight the weather I had a feeling  they're not coming back we are traveling  into an unknown  stay like  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]